The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: Today what
we're going to do
is we're going to talk about
some of the big ideas in class.
Today what we're going to do
is talk about pattern formation
in biology, some of the
different mechanisms
that are employed in development
and other contexts in order
for organisms to figure
out where to put things.
Now before I get
into that too much,
I wanted to make couple
administrative type
announcements.
So first, we have
graded the exams
and we'll hand them back
at the end of class today.
If I try to forget then
please somebody remind me.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to start by just talking
about diffusion a bit more.
I think that
there's a fair range
of different maybe experiences
thinking about diffusion
and what it can do for you.
So we'll work on our
intuition a little bit.
And then I'll say
something about the reading
that you did from
[INAUDIBLE] book
about robust mechanisms
for pattern formation
in the context of development.
So simple diffusion
with degradation leads
to these exponential
profiles that are not
robust to changes in the
concentration or production
rate of the morphogen.
Whereas if you have self
enhanced degradation then
this leads to power law
fall off it's more robust
to the concentration
of this morphogen.
Then what we're going to do
is transition to these turning
patterns, reaction
to fusion systems
where you can have a
really surprising effect,
whereby in a well mixed
situation these chemicals
or proteins or reactants,
they might just
reach a stable state.
However, once you add
diffusion, then you
can start getting
pattern formation, which
is a very funny thing because
diffusion is normally something
that's smooths out profiles.
Normally we think
about diffusion
as being something
that removes patterns
and indeed that's
generally what happens.
But following from
this class of work
from Alan Turing at
the end of his life,
he showed that it's
actually in principle
possible to have the emergence
of patterns from diffusion.
And we'll talk about some of
the ways that could possibly
happen.
So Turing patterns are already
a surprising case where
diffusion leads to patterns.
There's another
interesting phenomenon
where if you add another
source of noise that-- again,
you think noise, demographic
noise, the random creation
destruction of individuals
or chemicals or proteins.
Normally, we think this
should also kind of be
a force for removing patterns.
But there's been
a number of pieces
of work over the last decade
showing that in some cases,
demographic noise
can actually lead
to patterns either
in space or in time.
We're going to talk
more about this
in the context of these
so-called noise induced
predator-prey oscillations.
But since we're
talking about patterns
here I will tell you something
about how such noise can
enhance the
formations of patterns
in the context of
the Turing mechanism.
And then we'll end by talking
some about recent work of how
E. coli find the center of their
cell when they want to divide.
So you can imagine this
is not an obvious thing
to figure out how you might do.
And we'll talk about
the so-called Min system
that E. coli use to find
the center of the cells
so they know where
to septate, where
to cut off and make two cells.
So I just want to
start by making sure
that when we talk
about diffusion,
we're all talking
about the same thing.
Now, hopefully for
those of you that
have not been thinking about
diffusion so much recently,
you did read the notes that
Alexander Van Oudenaarden
put together for Systems
Biology a few years ago.
I think it's useful, but
in addition to the math,
as maybe many of you
know I'm a huge fan
of graphical
representations of ideas.
So I just want to
make sure that we all
agree on some of the basic
ideas of how, for example, we
get flux in the
context of diffusion.
So imagine that we
have a one dimension
system where there's some
chemical with concentration c.
We can imagine, for example, it
starts out looking like this.
This is a concentration profile
as a function of position
x where we have maybe
a box of length l.
Concentration of some chemicals
of function of position
x in some space.
Now I just want to make
sure that we're all
thinking about the same thing.
So it starts out some
concentration of c1,
over might be some c2.
Linearly here.
I just want to make
sure we all agree
on the magnitude of the flux
at some different points.
So, in particular, we can think
about A, B, this is capital C.
So where is the magnitude
of the flux largest?
A, B, C. D corresponds
to them being the same.
E as don't know.
Are there any questions
about the question?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: On the y-axis,
you're plotting concentration?
PROFESSOR: Yes, this
y-axis is the concentration
is the function of position x.
All right, I'll give another
five seconds to think about it.
All right, do you
need more time?
Let's vote.
Ready three, two, one.
OK, great.
So I'd say a vast
majority here are agreeing
that it's going to D. The
flux is going to the same
everywhere.
Now the flux-- can
somebody remind us?
We'll say the flux of J.
And what is it going to be?
So there's a minus D times the
change in c with respect to x.
This was derived in the notes.
So this is highlighting
that what leads to a flux
is the change in a concentration
with respect to position.
And so it doesn't matter that
the concentration is higher
here than here, we
have the same flux.
And the flux is in
which direction?
Left, right, up, down?
Three, two, one.
Left, so the flux is here.
Minus sign-- like always, it's
hard to remember from equations
whether they're plus
minus signs but you
should be able to just
remember you can draw something
like this and say OK,
this is a positive DCDX,
so flux is going to be in the
negative direction, right?
Now, what will be the change in
the concentration with respect
to time at this point right now?
So this is change in the
conservation at point
b with respect to time.
Is it greater than
0, equal to 0,
less than 0, or can't determine?
Does everybody understand the
question I'm trying to ask?
Change in the
concentration at this
point with respect to time,
at this time that's wrong.
I'll give you 5 seconds.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
OK.
And so this, again, it's
pretty good but not everyone.
So it is going to be b.
Can somebody explain
why it's b here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: There's as
much flux coming in
as coming out on the other side?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So it's true that there's a net
flux here coming to the left.
But from the sample, if we
want to know whether there's
a change in the
concentration at that point,
we need to know what's the
net number of particles moving
to the left verses the net
particle number there that
are coming in from the right.
Now of course, on this left
face-- if I draw a little box
here-- are all the particles
crossing this position?
Are they all moving to the left?
No.
So the idea is that all the
particle motion is random.
And indeed, there's
only a slight access
of particles moving to the
left as compared to the right.
In the sense that, if you look
at the concentration there,
the concentration
is rather large,
it's only a little
bit larger to right
than to the left of this plane.
Which means that there's only
a slight excess of particles
defusing to the left
as coming to the right,
but that leads to a net
flux of particles crossing
this plane to the left.
So where will the
concentration be changing?
At this point here
will the concentration
be changing with
respect to time?
Ready three, two, one.
No.
So well does it change at all
ever anywhere in this example?
Is this a steady state
profile, yes or no?
Ready three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
What should be the
steady state profile?
AUDIENCE: Flat.
PROFESSOR: Flat, OK.
So how does that come about
if the concentration is not
changing any?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It'll only
change at the edges.
PROFESSOR: It's only
changing the edges initially.
Now, it's important
to note that it's not
that the concentration
profile is not going
to start looking like this.
So that will not actually
be how it-- eventually it's
going to be flat.
But it's going to
smooth out on the edges.
Do you guys understand
what I'm trying to say?
It's not that it's a line
that kind of goes like this,
but instead we do end
up getting curvature.
One more of these,
and then we'll
consider ourselves to
be expert diffusionists.
All right, so let's
say the concentration
as a function of position
looks something like this.
What I want to know is,
where is DCDT maximal?
We have some different points.
We have A, B, C,
D. Five seconds.
Ready three, two, one.
All right, so we finally
got a lot of disagreement.
I like it.
Turn to your
neighbor, you should
be able to find somebody
that disagrees with you.
What is it that determines?
AUDIENCE: [ALL DISCUSSING]
PROFESSOR: All right,
did you guys all agree?
You all agree on it?
OK let's go ahead and reconvene.
And let me see, maybe
they were forming
the domains of some sort.
All right, ready.
Wait, he says, no, no.
All right, OK, one question.
AUDIENCE: Is this
instantaneous in some sense?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Exactly at the inset.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
I guess what I would say
is that this is
concentration profile
at some time as a function
of position in time.
If you want to know the
concentration profile
some time delta t later, right?
t plus delta t.
Well then, it's going to
be the concentration we
had before then a little bit.
Plus delta t times the
derivative with respect
to time.
Right, so this is the
concentrate file at this time.
And I want to how
much is it going
to change in the next delta t?
And I'm assuming, of
course, that I'm not
adding any particles or
taking any particles away.
So just do the diffusion.
All right, let's
see where we are.
Ready three, two, one.
OK.
All right so it's we got
domain, definitely some domains.
All right.
Well, it's going
to end up being A,
as I think the majority of
the group is now saying.
And why is it a?
AUDIENCE: Because of
the second derivative.
PROFESSOR: Second
derivative, right?
So just what we
said before is that,
if we wanted to know the
change of concentration
with respect of time, at
this point that was zero.
Because the flux particle was
leading that point and the flux
coming in were the same.
And we can also think about
the second derivative.
So this indeed just
from fix, like I said,
was first law/ we got a D, so
this gives second derivative c
with respect to x squared.
So that's a 2.
What this is saying is that,
to determine how rapidly
this concentration is going to
change at a particular point
with respect of
time, we need to know
the curvature of the
concentration with respect
to position.
So many people
were saying c here.
And actually, this is
where the concentration
will remain exactly constant
over this next delta t.
And of course, if
we want to know
about what the concentration
is going to do for a long time,
then we have to do
something more subtle.
But if we want to how
the concentration is
changing right now, then we
just look at the curvature.
And indeed, the curvature
here is maximal.
So concentration
DCDT at this point,
is it going to be
greater or less than 0?
Ready three, two, one.
PROFESSOR: Less than 0, right?
Now, it's true that only the
curvature at a particular point
and matter is to know how the
concentrations going to change
over this next delta t.
But if you want to
know about what's
going to happen over
longer periods of time,
than you have to worry about
more of the global structure.
And what's true is that this
local maximum may quickly
go away.
So you don't have to wait very
long before this thing gets
smooth and then DCDT will--
the magnitude will go to 0.
And sometimes this big hump
will stick around longer,
but because of the
curvature, this
has the maximal
magnitude of DCDT.
And it makes sense
that the concentration
is going to go down because the
net flux here is to the right
and to the left.
And so there's a net
flux, particles leaving,
concentration is
going to come down.
Now are there any questions
about what we've said?
If you find this
discussion confusing,
I would strongly encourage you
to get together with a friend
and just draw some
random lines, curves,
and just make sure
you understand
where diffusion is going to
pull things and so forth.
No questions?
All right, I just want
to say a few things
about the so-called French
flag model in development.
This is perhaps the most famous.
Does everybody know what
the French flag looks like?
What's that?
All right.
There are three stripes
and some orientation.
No, but the idea here is
just that a simple way
to specify a structure
across one axis
is to have a defusing chemical
or generally a protein.
And then based on the
concentration of that protein
or morphogen, you can just
have the tissue read out
what it's supposed to be,
or what it's supposed to do.
So the idea here
is that, you have
some morphogen that starts
maybe on one end of an embryo
and then diffuses.
So we end up with
some curve that
tells us about the
morphogen concentration
as a function of position.
This is a functional position.
So this is along the embryo.
Now the general challenge in
the context of development
is asking-- we
started this embryo
with many different
cells, they're
all genetically identical,
and they all start out maybe
without any positional
information.
They don't know where they are.
But what that
means is they don't
know they need to develop into
a head or a tail or something
in between.
Now what often happens is that
you can have a deposition often
by the mother so you have a
maternal deposition of, say,
RNA that leads to expression
of some morphogen on one end
and then it diffuses.
And based on the
concentration you
can say what part of the body
you should be developing into.
So the idea is you just
have these thresholds that
might be some M1, M2.
All right, now all
the cells over here
know that they should
maybe develop into a head.
Over here, they're going to
develop into the mid body.
And over down here it could
be the low body, for example.
So just from the
concentration that a cell
feels at a particular location.
So if you had a cell
right here, you just
say OK the concentration of
morphogens between M1 and M2
and then from that you know
what l you're supposed be.
Now if you have no
degradation within the body.
Let's just imagine you
say, that at one end is 0.
We're told morphogen
concentration is M0.
And let's say that the other
end, we know the morphogen
concentration is going to be 0.
Let's say there's a lot
of degradation at an end.
If there's no
degradation in between,
what should the profile
look like given these?
So, no.
All right.
So just diffusion with
these boundary conditions.
I'm going to draw some
options and hopefully you
can close your eyes and
imagine what it should be.
All right, we know that starts
out M0 over L is equal to 0.
Is it closer to A, B, C, or D?
Do you understand
what I'm asking?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: That is
a steady state.
PROFESSOR: This is the steady
state concentration profile
of the morphogen given there's
no degradation in the interior.
Ready three, two, one.
All right.
So at least a majority are
agreeing it's going to be B.
Although, there's a significant
minority that's saying A.
This is why I'm bring
this up because, we're
so used to seeing
exponential profiles
and think that you should
always be getting them.
And I want to be clear why
it's an exponential profile.
That's the thing we start
with, and for example
this model in [INAUDIBLE] book.
Noori's book, you get
exponential profiles
as a result of first
order degradation.
Whereas if you don't have any
degradation in the interior,
then we say, OK, DCD-- well,
do we want to use C or M now?
We'll use M, just
because now we're
thinking very particularly
for morphogen.
All so DMDT.
We want to know the
steady state profile.
We set this thing equal to 0.
Integrate twice.
Right, so we're going to get--
morphogen profile should just
be some Ax plus B, OK?
My line's kind of
crappy, I'm sorry.
However, when we have
first order degradation,
then we get these
exponential profiles.
Are there any questions about--?
AUDIENCE: Is it possible
to have [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
What does this require?
AUDIENCE: The morphogen
is generated into halves.
X equals 0 and then--
PROFESSOR: Degraded it at--
AUDIENCE: Disappearing.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right.
That's what I'm saying, is that
when I said that at the end
it was a 0, this means that we
have degradation at this point.
Any time that the morphogen
reaches the end of the embryos,
it gets degraded.
So it's not degradation inside
if it's only degradation here.
And this of course a situation
where you have constant flux
throughout the embryo,
constant rate of production
of the morphogen, constant
rate of degradation over here.
But when you have this
first order degradation--
if we're told that
instead-- well, maybe.
So, if in addition
to having diffusion,
you also have this
first order degradation.
Now remember M is a function
of both x and t, right?
And this is the situation where
we get exponential profiles.
Now in Murray's book,
he often discusses
this where the
boundary condition
is that you have some
concentration M0 at one end.
And then we get an
exponential profile here.
What was the characteristic
length scale?
This is something we should
be able to figure out.
You should, of course, be
able to solve the equations,
but you should be
able to figure it out
from our favorite approach
of dimensional analysis.
What's the units of things here?
So units of D is what?
Length squared over time.
Units of alpha?
So this is a morphogen
concentration over a time.
This is a morphogen
concentration.
So this thing has
to be one over time.
So the length
scale is then going
to have to go as the
square root of D over L.
And indeed, if you solve it,
it's exactly equal to that,
but this dimensional
analysis just told us
that it had to scale like that.
So this is telling us about
a characteristic length
of which this morphogen
profile is going to fall off.
This is the
characteristic length L.
Incidentally, you'll
see many cases
of things that look like this.
So if there's first
order rate that's
something is either degraded
or is uptaken or whatnot, then
together with diffusion, you'll
get an exponential profile
with a [INAUDIBLE] length scale
that's given by this ratio.
And you'll see this in
many different contexts
of, for example, nutrients
going into a biofilm.
If you have cells
picking up nutrients
then it's not that
it's being degraded,
but it's being imported.
Then you'll have
a similar process.
This is a nice, fine situation
except for what was the problem
that [INAUDIBLE] pointed out?
It's not robust.
It's not robust against what?
Initial condition.
Yes, but I think we have to be
a little more specific on that.
Right, it's not robust
to changes in M0.
Incidentally, in
most context, I think
for mathematical
simplicity, it's
useful to just have a banner
condition where M0 is constant.
But in general, is
that what the mother is
going to be fixing necessarily?
What would the mother
typically be fixing?
What was that?
AUDIENCE: Production rate.
PROFESSOR: Production rate.
How do we figure out
what the production
rate is in this situation?
That's right, the flux ware.
That's right.
The production rate is
the flux right at or just
to the right of 0.
Incidentally, where's
the flux maximal here?
Is it maximal at A, B, or C?
Ready three, two, one.
You can do it verbally.
Fun.
A. Right.
And that's because the
profile steepest here and then
shallows out.
So flux is decreasing here.
And that's because some of the
morphogen is being degraded.
So indeed, we can figure
out the production rate.
Right.
This is equal to the flux,
which is equal to minus
DCDX at that location.
Right, so the
morphogen profile M
is a function of x is
some M0e to the minus x
over L, where L is given by
this character of lengthscale,
right?
So if we ask what's DMDX?
Well, it's going to
be-- we get a minus M0
over L. Evaluated at x equal
to 0 just makes that go away,
so we end up with this.
So you figure out
what flux is, right?
Yeah, so, it's just an extra
couple terms, it's fine.
But that would be what
would typically be constant
because there might be
some RNA deposit there
or if it's actually
transcription off of the genes
at in the cells in
this location and then
it's based on whether there's
one or two copies and so forth.
So this is all fine, except
that this thing is not robust.
It changes in M0 or
this production rate.
Whereas in many cases,
what we seek experimentally
is that if we, for example,
have the production rate,
then the profile
that we see out here
is somehow remarkably similar.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yeah, OK.
So I'd say that in
many cases, it's
not that it's directly
this M squared business.
But there are a number of
cases in Drosophila, where
they actually do see this.
In many cases, it was a self
enhanced degradation but not
that it was directly, it was
via binding to a receptor.
So this was seen in
patch lists together.
I want to remember which
were the models that-- I'm
worried I'm always doing it
get so it's like patchless
and frizzled, or-- are
there any Drosophila people
here that came up with
these crazy names?
All right, yeah, so
I always got confused
which are the
morphogens and which
are the receptors
in these situations.
But I'd say that it
is something that's
observed in number of
different contexts,
at different stages of
development, both in Drosophila
and-- they see this in the
wing as well as in the body.
And so in different stages
I think it is signature.
But I'm very much not a
developmental biologist.
All right so the proposal that
[INAUDIBLE] suggests as a way
to make this thing more robust
is to somehow change this term.
Now, the goal in all this was
to have some degradation rate.
And he writes it as F is
a function concentration
M. In principle,
this thing could
be a function of the position
x, but he doesn't want that.
And why was it that
he didn't want that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because we
already know [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, right.
So the whole goal
is that we want
to start with some
situation where
we don't know where we are
as a function of position x.
And then from that get
some spatial information.
So we really want
something that's
not a function of x in there.
Because then we've
already solved the problem
that we're trying to address.
And so one proposal
is indeed just
to have something
that-- and this is
very much a phenomenological
approach-- which
is to have this thing be
self enhanced degradation.
So the idea is that here if we
have the morphogen profile that
looks something like this.
There are multiple
ways you can have
something that looks like this.
So if along the way to
degradation, if the morphogen
actually binds the receptor, but
then activates the degradation.
And this is seen, for
example, in Drosophila.
This is Hedgehog and Patched.
So R is-- in this case,
you have the morphogen
is diffusing outside the cells.
It binds to the receptor,
and then the receptor
activates imported
degradation of the morphogen.
So it's not that the
morphogen is directly
leading to its own degradation,
but it's via some network here.
And there was another
one that they talk about,
which is that, when the
degradation is mediated by 2.
These look like this,
and this is in context.
And this is again Drosophila,
but you could probably
guess what this thing does.
And so it is a wing
development as well.
If you write down an actual
model of one of these things,
and you could play
with it and see
where you're going to get
something that's going to look
like an M squared type term.
But the nice thing about this
phenomenological approach
is it kind of gives you a
sense of the kinds of effects
that you should be looking
for that will enhance
the robustness of the pattern.
Now the key thing in this
whole discussion to remember
is that if you have a
profile here, if you change,
it's just somehow
translationally
invarion in the sense
that since there's
no information about
where you are here,
these patterns can
kind of slide over.
So if you change the
boundary condition M0,
that's just equivalent to
sliding this over some distance
and you could figure out
where everything has to go.
And that's true not just
for the exponential profile,
but for any of the profiles.
And that's just because there's
no information about what's
going on once you're
inside the embryo.
Can somebody give the
intuitive explanation
for why some sort of self
enhanced degradation like this
might make the
pattern more robust?
AUDIENCE: Decrease
faster [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Decrease
faster when M is big.
That's right.
And so the idea is that
if you change the M0 here,
for example, you double
it, then with a self
enhanced degradation you
kind of quickly come back
to where you were.
So there's some sense that if
the pattern quickly comes down,
then you can get it
being more robust.
In particular, this
profile for large x
in the proper regime,
this thing falls off
as some A a over x squared.
And indeed, one of the
problems in Murray's book
is that if this is just
degrading as M to some power n,
then you can calculate
what happens here.
But this is some sort
of power law fall off.
So of course, it's falling
off rapidly here, but not
as rapidly as if it
were an exponential.
And this is just like in
the case of the power law
distributions of networks
that we were talking about
before, that for the
exponential fall off,
then it's just
very, very unlikely
that you'll find some
node with many edges.
Similarly here, you quickly
fall to zero here as compared
to a power law distribution.
So that means that you can
specify patterns out further
in some sense.
Are there any questions
about this basic idea
and where it comes from?
I think the discussion
in [INAUDIBLE] book
is actually reasonable.
So I don't really want to
spend too much time on it.
In the context of
the eldar model
that was from the last
section of that chapter.
One thing I just
want to highlight
is that it's useful to be
able to look at these models,
and from the equations
that you see-- for example,
the supplemental
material of a paper--
make sure you are very clear
about what assumptions they've
made in getting to this model.
And so maybe we'll just spend a
few minutes talking about this.
So this is again a
Drosphil embryo two,
two and a half hours
after fertilization
where at that stage, you
really have the embryo that
looks like a-- we're trying
to understand the patterning
around the front back.
So we think about diffusion
along in one dimension,
but it's really around
this radial direction.
And in particular, where this is
trying to understand patterning
in the dorsal region.
And what we have is
a situation where we
have this protease inhibitor.
And so the protease
distributed uniformly.
Inhibitor starts out
out there, and then we
have the morphogen that
somehow starts out in here.
And we want to end
up with a situation
where the morphogen profile in
here is kind of well defined.
So where you just
have the morphogen
at the center of
this dorsal region.
And then we have diffusion
of these inhibitors
coming in and then the
morphogen coming out.
And the question is, how
can we make sense of this?
And if you look at the equations
that they write down-- So
we have diffusion
of the inhibitor.
This is the complex
of the inhibitor
and the morphogen-- complex c.
And so this is a case
where they wrote down
what they basically knew
about the biologists system.
And then they asked, well,
what range of parameters
would lead to a robust pattern
of the morphogen in here,
if you vary things such as the
total concentration inhibitor,
the morphogen or the protease?
So we have diffusion of each
of these things, the inhibitor,
the morphogen complex.
We're not going to worry
about the protease,
because this thing is
uniformly distributed.
You can argue about whether
that's the right thing to do,
but that's based on the model.
So we have diffusion
of each of these guys.
Can somebody say
what's going on here?
What are these things
trying to capture?
John?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this
is just saying,
OK, the complex is formed
as a result of binding
of the inhibitor
and the morphogen.
It's proportional to
concentration those two things,
at that particular position
at the particular time.
And just remember that any
time that you create something,
if you have binding at
two things together,
then you have to consider
these things going away.
And it's not they're
being degraded,
it's just that they're
forming this complex.
So in these equations
you just have
to be very careful
about keeping track
of which things are
really going away
and which things are
just changing form.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
You're saying why that
there's not a minus term?
So this is an assumption.
And I think this
is a kind of thing
that you have to be clear
about in any of these,
because that's always going
to occur at some rate.
And the assumption is
that this is dominant.
And then just be clear in
words, what is this thing?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
The protease.
And you're saying
cleaving inhibitor.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
cleaving the compacts
by degrading the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So at a rate proportional to
the Proteus concentration--
the complex concentration--
this complex goes away.
Now the question is we have
to figure out where it went
or what happened, right?
Well we have a
minus alpha c here
but then we have a
plus alpha c here.
But this isn't the
morphogen right.
This is at the rate
that the complex somehow
is being disappeared
by the protease,
the morphogen is appearing.
But then, we don't have
the same term here.
And that's how you know that
what the protease is doing
is it's degrading the inhibitor
as part of the complex.
So by looking at
these equations,
you can actually figure out
what are the assumptions that
have been made of
what the biology is
that's being captured here.
But in many cases, there are
assumptions of what's big
and what's small.
And then what's this thing here?
Somebody else that has not
yet-- do these equations
look familiar?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: It's the
protease [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
It's the protease degrading the
inhibitor when the inhibitor is
not down to the
morphogen. Now of course,
what the authors did next
is they searched numerically
across parameter space
over [INAUDIBLE] magnitude,
and they found that for
some parameter regime
there was a robust pattern
of the morphogen developed
in here.
There's no reason for you
to necessarily remember
which thing it was.
But what they found is
that if this term went away
and this term went
away, then you
end up getting a robust
profile of the morphogen
against changes in the
overall morphogen inhibitor
concentration.
Now this is pretty
weird, I would say.
I don't know, do you
think-- is this one weird?
Weirdness is in the
eye of the beholder.
But I would say it's
not so shocking.
Can somebody say verbally
what this would correspond to?
AUDIENCE: The protease
doesn't degrade the inhibitor
on its own.
PROFESSOR: That's right,
the protease doesn't degrade
the inhibitor on
its own, only when
it's part of the complex
with the morphogen.
And independently there was
experimental data already
indicating that was true.
So you could have if
you want to just written
the model without that,
because there was already
evidence for that.
But as I said, this is
a pretty weird thing.
And so, this would be saying
that, for some reason,
diffusion of the morphogen
on its own is very small.
In particular, small compared
diffusion of the morphogen
when it's a complex.
Now can somebody say why I
might think that's weird?
You don't have to
believe it's weird.
AUDIENCE: You'd think
bigger is better.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Exactly.
This is saying, well, when
it's complex, it's bigger,
it's somehow diffusing faster.
So this would not happen do
the simple Stokes type drag.
This would have to be biology.
Somebody's biology is allowed
to do anything that doesn't
violate the laws of physics.
Indeed, later there was
experimental evidence
of something like this
was actually happening.
And you could
imagine having either
from sort of active transport
type dynamics for the complex,
or from binding type
dynamics of the morphogen.
I think the key thing to
take from this example
is just that, in
general, we would
like biological function--
biology would like
biological function to be
robust to things that are often
fluctuating or varying.
And that's one way to try to
make guesses about what might
be happening in the system.
This sort of
computational exercise
is not all a proof that this
has to be what's happening.
They wrote down a
particular model--
it could have been that there
are other terms they're not
aware of and so forth.
But it's at least a way
of generating hypotheses
that you can go and test.
And quite generally,
I'd also say
that its essential for all
of us as consumers of models
to be able to look at
some of these equations
and figure out what it
is that they've assumed.
I want to move on to
this idea of pattern
formation via the
reaction diffusion
or Turing-type patterns.
And I think it's
really important
to start by just acknowledging
that this is really
a surprising finding, that
it's even possible for this
to happen.
Because this is
a situation where
you have a couple
chemicals-- or proteins,
or reacting elements--
and if you just mix them,
if you have them in
some well mixed tube,
they reach some steady state.
Whereas somehow if
you allow diffusion,
then you can get these patterns.
And I would say based on
my intuition at least,
I would not have thought
that this would be possible.
And this really just is because
if you can just imagine,
you start with some profile.
Now there's some structure here.
But diffusion's going
to actually cause
this to come down,
and this to come up.
So diffusion acts to remove
these spatial patterns.
But somehow in
some prime regimes,
if you have coupled
reactions that
are activating and
inhibiting each other,
then you can actually get
these spatial patterns.
And as you read about,
there's some idea
that you need to have
a local activation
and a global inhibition.
But ultimately the
mathematical-- you always
have to go and think about
more carefully about the math,
and would be indicated
just by those words.
This is at least a way to guide
your thinking a little bit.
But ultimately what
matters are around this
stable what would be
the stable fixed point,
you have to actually look at
these derivatives and so forth.
And the derivatives can
be subtle I would say.
Just because you
think of something
as activator
inhibitor doesn't mean
that it's going to have that
role around the fix point
that you're studying.
So this is just a caution.
What I want to do
is just give you,
for example, one example
of a simple model
that does experience
these Turing patterns.
And in an appropriate regime.
And this Levin-Segel model
of pattern formation.
And this was published in
1976, and it was actually
meant as a model of
predator-prey interactions
in ecology.
We'll talk
significantly more about
predator-prey interactions
in a few weeks.
But I just want to write
down what they said.
And this is a simplified
model of their stuff.
So it's actually trying to think
about some plankton herbivore
before interactions.
And this is derivative
with respect to time.
We're going to follow the
nomenclature of a paper
by Butler and Goldenfeld
a few years ago,
because they're the
ones who thought
about the demographic noise
enhancing the patterns.
PROFESSOR: All right, so we have
[? phi ?] and [? phi. ?] First
of all, who's eating whom?
All right, we're going
to say it verbally.
Who is the predator?
Ready three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Herbivore.
PROFESSOR: Herbivore.
Herbivores are not
what they used to be.
So indeed, the herbivore
benefits from the presence
of the plankton.
So nobody cares about
plankton, I guess.
So this corresponds to the
predator-prey type interaction.
So there's some death rate.
So let's see, the
herbivore or the predator.
And then what you see is
there's these two growth
terms for the plankton.
So there's this term,
which would be kind
of simple, exponential growth.
And then this term,
which is actually
some sort of super
exponential growth.
There's some sense in which the
plankton benefit each other.
And this was originally
introduced because of something
called predator satiation.
But it's just a general
reflection of the fact
that in many cases, individuals
benefit from the presence
of other individuals.
And in particular, this is
known as the ally effect,
and we'll spend time talking
about this in a few weeks
as well in the context of
populations and ecology.
For now, I just want to use this
as an example of a model that
gives you these Turing patterns.
So if you want to, you can
go ahead and ask, well,
what happens if we just
have a well mixed situation?
If everything is not a
function of x, but it's still
can to be a function of time.
You can solve these
equations, and you
can find what the steady
states are equal to.
So there is indeed a steady
state stable coexistence
of the predator and the prey
in a well mixed situation.
However, if you then
go and you analyze
the stability of different
spatial modes, what you'll find
is that in some situations,
particular wavelength or wave
vectors become unstable.
And it's just over some
range of wavelengths,
and that corresponds to the wave
length of the Turing patterns
that you'll see.
If you're curious about
these things in more depth,
I encourage you to attend Mehran
Kardar's class Statistical
Physics in Biology, he is
an expert on these topics
and I think is a
wonderful clear lecturer.
Now there's going to be some
condition for these things
leading to Turing patterns.
Now from your reading, do you
think it's going to be mu--?
So this is Turing patterns
require-- I'll give you
30 seconds to think about what.
Do you need more time?
I'm not sure where we are.
Maybe another 15
seconds just to--
Let's see where we are.
Ready three, two, one.
OK, we're all over the place.
I think we're uniformly
distributed between A, B,
and C. So there's
an idea that you're
supposed to have
so-called local activation
and global inhibition.
Why don't we turn to a neighbor
and see if you can figure out
what's going on.
OK, why don't we
reconvene, I'm curious
where you're thinking is.
Let's go ahead and vote.
Ready three, two, one.
OK, so we have many, many C's.
The idea that some mu has
to be much less the nu.
Yes.
I want to make sure.
All right, mu is telling us
about the diffusion coefficient
of the prey.
Nu is the diffusion
coefficient of the predator.
So what you want is to
have local activation.
And the thing that's activating
itself is the plankton.
So you can see that that's like,
for example, psi squared term.
And from the stand point of a
spatial situation, you can say,
all right, well, let's
say we have some region
with a lot of this prey.
Well, it's able to activate
itself, so it kind of comes up.
And as it does that, it is
creating more of the predator,
phi.
But because the predator has a
larger diffusion coefficient--
well, it's obviously
going to grow here.
But it will also diffuse away.
And that's this
global inhibition
of neighboring regions.
Now of course, these
are just words,
you have to take it a little
bit of a grain of salt.
But if you can actually do
this calculation analytically,
and derive in this
model the condition
for Turing patterns to emerge
as a function of everything.
And for example, if
you have b 1/2, p 1.
So for unity type parameters,
then the requirement
to get Turing patterns
is that nu over mu
is the greater than 27.8.
The key thing though
is that this thing
is much larger than 1.
So a general thing that emerges
in these Turing patterns
is that you need this
so-called inhibiting type
partner to have a much larger
effective diffusion coefficient
than the activating partner.
Now the problem with this
is that this thing is indeed
much larger than 1, which limits
the overall usefulness of this
is a mechanism.
Because if it really is simple
diffusion, how much bigger
would the-- let's say, low
Reynolds number regime,
these are just molecules
experience diffusion.
How much bigger does the--
this is so confusing.
So this is big and
this is little, right?
So how much bigger
does the activator--
they're too many things
to keep track of here.
It's because I don't have
anything written down.
So that's the activator.
So this one's the activator,
and this one's the inhibitor.
And the inhibitors has
to diffuse much more
than the activator.
So the inhibitor has to be much
smaller than the activator.
OK good, so how much bigger
does the activator have
to be than the inhibitor
for this to be true?
Does it scale as this 28
or 28 squared or 28 cubed?
In terms of radius, how much?
Scales linearly, remember?
Einstein equation, you guys had
fun thinking about on the exam.
KT over gamma.
This would require, for
example, the activator
to be 30 times bigger
in terms of radius.
And the inhibitor,
in order to have this
emerge just as a result of
diffusion, simple diffusion.
And that's just
not a typical thing
for just a range
of protein sizes.
But you could imagine
putting up various ways
to make this happen.
But there is a very nice
development that I mentioned,
which is that there's another
surprising aspect in these
problems, which is
that in many cases,
demographic noise can
lead to patterns-- --
or maybe you might call
them quasi-patterns.
But things that, for all
intents and purposes, look
like some of this
pseudo-periodic.
So there's a pseudo-Turing
pattern, maybe.
And indeed, if you
actually do this simulation
with those parameters
where you do
the explicit demographic
fluctuations-- i.e.
you take into account
that this corresponds
to a prey giving birth.
This corresponds to a
predator eating a prey,
random events just
like what we've
done in the context of
a Gillespie simulation.
Then what you find is that
with demographic fluctuations
or demographic noise, then
the condition here nu over mu
has to be only 2.48.
And indeed in Butler
and Goldenfeld,
they derive these things using
field theoretic approaches.
There was a 2011 paper
and also 2008 or 2009.
The nice thing here
is that what you
see is that in the presence of
these demographic noise that
will be there, the difference
in diffusivity that are required
is not nearly as large
as when you're thinking
about the mean field equations.
Are there any
questions about this
before we talk about
center fighting in E. coli?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, now
you're thinking
about the actual
plankton-herbivore.
I think there are
many things to say.
One of them would just be that
maybe the patterns that you
see between actual plankton
and actual herbivores
is not due to the
Turing mechanism.
For the Turing
mechanism to be at play
to generate spatial
patterns, it requires
that this inhibitor do
something equivalent
to diffusion more rapidly.
It has to have to move
away more rapidly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
It could be on the plankton only
move around on the currents,
whereas the herbivore
actually has direct motions.
I have to say, I don't actually
know enough about plankton
to know whether this is at
all-- That base statement I thin
is true, but I don't know
how the numbers work out.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Both in this case and the simple
predator-prey oscillations.
One thing we're going to see
the predator-prey populations
later is that you can also
get this sort of oscillations
in time.
So this could be in time or this
could be a function of space.
But in both cases,
it's really that you
have a resonant
enhancement in some areas.
So that the demographic
fluctuation somehow
excite all frequencies
or all wavelengths.
But then what happens
is that, in this case,
if you look at the eigenvalues--
OK, I want to be close to 0,
though.
If you look at how
the modes decay--
so the eigenvalue's function
of a wave number-- what you see
is that you end up getting
things that look like this.
So whereas a Turing
pattern is when
particular wave
length or wave modes
actually becomes
unstable, and then you
get mean field type patterns.
And in this situation
what happens
is that you're just close here,
so then you excite all the wave
numbers or wavelengths.
And then some of them take
a long time to go away,
so then they build up and then
that's the resulting patterns
that you see.
So what I want to do is
just for the last 10 minutes
to talk about this Min system.
Because it's I think
it's a beautiful example
of a combination of Systems
Biology questions together
with reaction diffusion
systems, and also
some beautiful in
vitro experiments
that I've quite appreciated.
So the question is--
imagine yourself,
you've gone to all this work
right, so now you're nice
and long.
So you'd like to
divide into two cells.
And the question is, how do
you know where to divide?
So you imagine that
you're some E. coli cell.
You're maybe six microns
long, everything is great.
And the question is,
you want to divide?
Where would you like to divide
if you're an E. coli cell?
Middle.
OK, so what you'd
like to do is go here.
And indeed, what happens is that
there's the so-called z-ring.
There's a a
pseudo-polymer protein
that forms a ring
around here, then
it constricts itself and
pinches off the membrane.
And that's how
you get two cells.
So there's this
formation of this z-ring
that constricts and that's
this cell division event.
The question is how do
you know where to put it?
And that's what this
Min system is for.
And it's, of course,
like everything
in bacterial genetics, it
was identify by mutations.
So the Min system it's called
that because these mutants
formed so-called mini cells.
If you, instead of
dividing the center where
you might have two copies
of the genome here.
If instead you divide
over here, then what
your going to end up
with is a very long cell
with two copies of the genome.
You're going to end up with
this mini cell without any DNA.
And those mini
cells, are they going
to do well for the long term?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Right.
They actually can
survive for a little bi.
And people have argued
that maybe that could
be useful for synthetic
biology because they still
make proteins, but they're not
going to go take over the world
because they don't have any DNA.
But these are the
so-called mini cells
that happen if you have
mutations in The min system.
Now, I think the three players
are MinC, MinD, and MinE.
So I think that MinA and MinB
ended up not actually existing
or something, in the sense that
they identified the mutants,
but then they were
wrong about something.
So the three that
actually ended up
being involved in the actual
Min system are C, D and E.
So this MinC prevents
formation of the z-ring.
Now MinD and MinE are
kind of the amazing guys.
So this guy binds to the
membrane and recruits MinC.
Whereas MinE-- what it does is
it pulls MinD off the membrane.
So it binds to MinD and
ejects from the membrane.
And what has been seen by doing
imaging in live E. coli cells
with fluorescently
labeled MinD and MinE
is that there are remarkable
oscillations from pole to pole.
And indeed, that
doesn't require MinC,
so MinC is somehow
following the others.
What happens is that
MinD binds over here,
then MinE binds
and pushes it off.
And then the MinD
comes over here,
and then MinE pulls it off,
and it goes back and forth.
The period is minutes, maybe.
So it's a really remarkable
thing that happens in vivo.
And the idea of what's happening
is that if MinD comes here
and then it comes here,
on each of the edges,
then it doesn't hang
out in the middle.
And that means that it's only in
the middle where MinC can then
bind-- oh, sorry.
Because MinC is following
MinD, then only in the middle
can you form the z-ring, because
that's where MinC is not.
Right.
It's wonderful to do
things in live cells
because that's the native
context and so forth.
But I think that in some
cases, it's also wonderful
if you can take
purified components
and recapitulate interesting
behaviors in vitro.
Because then at
least you know what
is sufficient to generate
a particular kind
of dynamical behavior.
And because this system
had been proposes
as a model system for
reaction diffusion mechanism
to get this behavior.
And so there's this
paper by Martin Loose,
in Petra Schwille's
lab in-- where was it?
In Dresden.
And what they did is they took
a supported lipid bilayer-- so
a membrane on
glass-- and then they
added purified components
of MinD and MinE
that were fluorescently labeled.
And then they saw
amazing patterns,
these amazing reaction
diffusion waves traveling along.
Now on the first day
of lecture, I actually
showed you what some of
those things look like.
I didn't want to use
up the projector again,
but maybe I can
pull up this movie
because it is kind of fabulous.
So maybe you can't see
these things very well.
But this is a MinD and MinE
and an overlay of the two,
imaged on a two
dimensional membrane.
And the movies are just amazing.
When you see this, you think
that it's a simulation.
It's so incredible
watching these things go.
After class, you can come
up, I can show you the paper,
and you can look at the
movie in more depth.
But they're really
amazing patterns,
and it's patterns
that you would predict
from some sort of Turing type
reaction diffusion mechanism.
So there are few things
that are may be worth
saying in this business.
So these are fluorescently
labeled MinD, MinE.
They started out with
MinD that was uniform.
And then they added MinE,
and over the time scale
of about an hour they started
seeing these sorts of patterns.
And as maybe you expected
from the in vivo behavior,
what you see are these things
where MinD looks like this,
whereas MinE looks like that.
And then the wave
travels here to the left.
Because the MinE is ejecting
the MinD from the membrane,
causing this whole
thing to move.
So this is a situation
where you have
both of these proteins
in the liquid.
All right, so in buffer, as well
as on the membrane and they're
coming on and off and so forth.
And in this situation,
it's wonderful
because they can do all
sorts of things like control
the concentration
of MinE, and see
that the velocity of
these waves changes as you
change concentration in MinE.
So this is a really
experimentally trackable
system.
And then you can ask
what kind of model
would lead to that
sort of behavior?
Such waves, do you think
that it requires ATP?
Just for fun, we can vote
yes or no, it's all right.
Ready three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So indeed it does require ATP.
And that's a general
feature of these Turing type
patterns is that there is
a non-equilibrium structure
formation.
Now one nice thing you can
do in this sort of system
is you can ask, well,
what happens if I
photo bleach a particular area?
So I come in and I photo bleach.
So now the profile
looks like-- I locally
deplete the fluorescence here.
Question is, will this move
together with the traveling
wave, or does it stay fixed?
And in these mechanisms, do
you think should this locally
depleted area, should it move
or should it stay where it is?
Do you understand the question?
Move, yes/no.
Ready three, two, one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It
actually doesn't move.
Depleted area doesn't move.
And this is just a reflection.
These waves are not the result
of individual molecules moving
together with the wave.
A wave like what you see in
the ocean, or on a stream,
or what not.
So the motion is a result of
the individual molecules coming
and going and communicating
with each other,
but it's not a reflection
of actual molecules
having directed motion.
Because indeed,
there's no mechanism
in these models for
directed motion.
What you see is that
in all these models,
the only thing that is
a function of position
is diffusion terms.
So it's all random diffusion,
but then you get global motion.